mais tu voudrais changer de quartier
[Musique]
c'est bien
lors de la préparation du menu à la
carte parmi les 22 séquences proposées
plusieurs déplacements touristiques avec
été suggérés dont la Tour Eiffel
Versailles et le quartier de la rue
bouffetard en plein cœur du quartier
latin quartier dans le marché célèbre
dans ces rues pittoresques constitue une
survivance du vieux balle par quatre
voix sur 6 les jeunes choisir la rue
Mouffetard ils allaient passer rue de
matinée à rencontrer des commerçants des
artisans et aussi des lycéens en grève
[Musique]
et avant j'étais un petit village
ouais enfin tout le monde se connaît
même maintenant tout le monde se connaît
tout le monde connaît les uns les autres
saradote mais tu voudrais changer de
quartier
[Musique]
c'est bien
les clocheurs qui vendaient tout
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
des enfants des bijoux
on peut prendre une bague là
[Musique]
chercher comme ça pourquoi est-ce que
c'est des gens des copains
[Musique]
je trouve enfin dans des trucs horribles
il y a une certaine jeunesse ici qui a
pas mal voyages toi tous les gens tous
les gens qui s'y
il y a pas mal de meetnik il y a pas mal
de gens qui ont fait la route et
il faut bien leur vendre quelque chose
est-ce qu'il y en plaît et c'est ça qui
leur plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
renseignez-vous
voilà et bien actuellement le
gouvernement tant à mettre en place tout
un projet de réforme de l'enseignement
alors la réforme avis qui concerne les
lycées et les écoles primaires et la
réforme Soissons qui concerne le second
cycle et les étudiants
mais nous soutenons également les
revendications des lycéens parce que ce
système tant à instaurer une sélection
des la maternelle la société comme elle
était avant pour l'évolution de toute
façon les structures ne changeront pas
c'est pas le gouvernement qui va changer
ses structures
et puis enfin en particulier pour les
étudiants enfin tu sais que en France
c'est le bac
en ce moment encore avec ton bas tu peux
rentrer à l'université sans examen ce
qui te permet de choisir plus ou moins
ce que tu veux aussi alors avec la
réforme à vie il y a beaucoup de il y
aura à la fin de la première
c'est-à-dire l'année avant le bac un
espèce d'examen général qui sera en fait
un diplôme de fin d'études et pour ceux
qui voudront entrer à l'université il y
aura un super bac si tu veux c'est à
dire que le
il faudra que tu prennes des options
très précises c'est à dire avant même
d'avoir ton bas il faudra que tu saches
dans quelle branche de l'université tu
vas te diriger
c'est quand même mieux non pour pour
l'économie de la France c'est comme ça
ce sera dirigé quand même
50 médecins on en fera pas ces 50 et il
y aura pas tant de chômeurs mais oui
mais ce qui reste qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire
[Musique]
nous sommes en grève sachez pourquoi